hello there reject nation i'm gonna
watch
constantine
okay i'm gonna watch constantine for the
first time ever in my entire life i'm
gonna watch this movie i've never even
seen a full movie clip of this so yeah
this is gonna be like a brand new
experience for me other than the fact
that i of course seen constantine and
those dc tv shows the dc animated shows
and movies and of course you know some
comic book appearances i've never
actually read a constantine comic book
solo before shame shame on me i should
be sent to hell for it i definitely have
some familiarity with the character
anyways guys i've heard this is an
underappreciated gem i love me some
kiana reeves leave a like that'd be very
much appreciated also subscribe and
click that notification bell to get
notified when we got a reaction of the
my peek your interest of course full
length ratchet watch alongs where you
sync up with your own copy for
constantine i'm watching this off
netflix actually available for super
sexy rejects over at our patreon page
become a super sexy reject today check
out all the exclusive shows
that we actually cover over there lastly
the team at prepper i think you probably
me added down these highlights let's
raise some hell
warner brothers okay i might need to
stop
oh god
cool
good information
[Music]
is that the spear of destiny
of course
it's amazing not predictable getting hit
by a car has become
oh [ __ ] nice fake out
hey philippines flag she doesn't look
filipino
holy christ
angel city
[Music]
i think
i think i found someone oh what's that
actor's name he's so good
homie does have a swagger though
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Applause]
oh damn
wow that was crazy
[Music]
nice
satanism and witchcraft
this is kramer oh [ __ ] child above
jazz kramer [ __ ]
lift it up
whatever happens
said don't work
oh no
smile pretty big
whoa
cool
she looks filipino
[Applause]
that was awesome
i do like the composition of these shots
does feel like a graphic novel anything
unusual
you let me know you don't need its
protection
like back in the day
okay
for you john i don't get it she baited
him
i killed a man today
what i didn't even
see his face i just pulled the trigger
and he went away most cops go 30 years
without firing their guns
this is a real fun demonic movie
[Music]
so many crosses
[Applause]
wicked shot damn
no one prepped me for how cool this
movie's gonna look
it's got that like things
cool gothic horror action things most
people never even heard of
and now i'm gonna be done by this
make arrangements no need
i already know exactly where i'm going
heaven he's going to heaven
no
give us the room please
what
should i have like a
she does
yeah it took me a second to realize he
called her angela
isabel wouldn't kill herself
she wouldn't kill herself detective
period detect period angie
there were security cameras
damn that was a
real snot tear coming off her nose there
hold the door keep going down if i can
help
[Music]
oh no
death follows him wherever he goes
yeah easy there hero
it's dragon's breath i thought you
couldn't get it anymore yeah well a liar
i don't know what god knows him
awesome
[Music]
may i take your coat mr constantine no
thanks i'm not gonna be staying long
how about you ma'am
oh no i'm not staying whoa
i really need to speak with him it's
very important first come first served
so you're rude no matter where you are
this kind of feels like i'm watching the
crow meet supernatural
i know what you want son
to tell them haven't i served him enough
what does he want from me only the usual
self-sacrifice
everything you've ever done you've only
ever done for yourself oh my god to earn
your way back into his good graces
possible rules endless regulations who
goes up who goes down
why
i'm not constantly inside about this
he's still doing the right
you masturbated too much when you were a
teenager
you smoked 30 cigarettes a day since you
were 15.
and you're going to go to hell
because of the life you took
you're [ __ ]
catholicism
you always had a rotten sense of humor
and his punchlines are killers
constantine it's raining josh
hey
oh there's quiznos subs in the
background i i haven't seen a quiznos in
years are they out of business
so much damage had been done to the
bodies
oh [ __ ] homeboy represses his powers
[Applause]
hey what do you know
i'm so sorry see
what is the security camera with this
amazing shot
hello
daniel crud you lucky s.o.b
yep
this is my nightmare
my phones
never stop ringing
oh my god
oh
what the [ __ ] is going on
oh
[Music]
what a wicked design
oh [ __ ]
oh look this is so cool
don't get up
you've been absent sometime
have you come here with relics to sell
jamon hanzo man so many comic book
movies disguising a full-fledged demon
here on our plane clearly i do not have
to remind you that is impossible and
yesterday i saw a soldier demon trying
to chew its way out to a little girl
listen john
demons stay in hell
angel's in heaven
the great the taunt of the original
superpowers thanks for the history
lesson
something's coming
oh spooky
balthazar that expression alone has
make my entire night
i'll make your night
i'll deport you sorry that's right you
stand for the [ __ ]
you know the rules of my house
while here you will abide by them no
killing in the continental i didn't
catch it
he's gonna bump into trinity
welcome to my life
what a cruel thing to do to a spider
my sister was murdered yesterday she was
a patient at raven's car she
jumped off the roof
i thought you said she was murdered
yeah well isabelle wouldn't have taken
her own life
yeah what kind of mental patient kills
herself what an [ __ ]
mr constantine i think they brainwashed
her into stepping off that roof some
kind of legion or um a cult well i
thought that with your background you
could at least
point me in the right direction
yeah okay sure
her soul would go straight to hell
where she'd be ripped apart over and
over and screaming brutal agony
for all eternity god damn you
i do embody that cool filled noir
quality
she's doing such a specific american
accent i don't believe in the devil you
should
he believes in you
see the devil
[Music]
oh no this is just downtown l.a like
every other week
close your eyes
why
suit yourself
wowie
historic core district what were those
things
scavengers damned
it's possible mary's gonna grab you i
really believe she wouldn't commit
suicide
isabelle never in a million years
let's be sure let's see if she's in hell
[Music]
that bus passing was scarier than when
manuel got hit at the beginning this is
crazy
yes
i need you to leave
but leave your cat
be careful with that cat
god i hate this part
he's not gonna hurt the cat is he
[Music]
this movie is visually awesome
capital records in the back
oh my goodness
nice i love it
like the upside down
isabel
is this like actual hell
or some purgatory
[Music]
is the cat okay
how is this possible i need to eat
so he's got such a sad face i'm always
so worried this guy any movie i see him
in i feel like death is just
waiting around the corner for him
earth 616.
how did he just get in here
[Music]
i think the security guard would have
run after him
[Music]
oh
[ __ ]
oh that was great visuals how they do
that
[Music]
so they messed the cgi the liquid
ah poor guy
so is having a drink like uh
does it help suppress all this [ __ ]
ow
ow please stop for the love of god what
are you doing that for man
what the [ __ ] is happening to him
oh my god
he did what most parents would do
they made it worse
officially i was dead for two minutes
when i came back all the things i could
see were heaven and hell right here the
world behind the world
and we're smack in the middle
be nice if you saw heaven a little more
so instead we get what i call half
breeds
the influence peddlers influencers
so when a half breed breaks through
woods
i deport their sorry ass straight back
to hell i don't get them all but i've
been hoping to get enough to ensure my
retirement
i'm a suicide angela
when i die the rules say i've got just
one place to ah
what would you do if you were sentenced
to a prison where half the inmates were
put there by you i guess god has a plan
for all of us
god's a kid with an ant farm he's not
planning anything when we were little as
well saw things too
oh just when we were about to get super
substantial information drawn himself in
alcohol in under a minute could have
been a member of my fraternity what the
hell is he doing here
he's okay he's batman
[Music]
what do you mean
how
there's some really neat art design in
this she told everyone about the things
she said she saw and then she stopped
talking for almost a year
so you had her committed
yeah how long two weeks this time did
you wait to answer that question when
you move to that room what did she do
angela i don't know
what did she do angela
you know what she did what are you
worried about what did she do angela
what did she do
[Music]
that was a quite aggressive there man we
would leave each other messages
and light and breath
[Music]
john there is no 17th act in corinthians
there is in the real bible
they have bibles in hell
it paints a different view of
revelations
says the world will not end by god's
hand but be reborn in the embrace of the
dead
oh good
this is the sign of my mind
the son of the devil
it says
oh my god are we gonna have jesus and my
mom fight each other my mom has no
patience uh for his father's rule and
yearns to forge his own kingdom
of fire and blood
disobedient little [ __ ] says first
ramon would have to possess a very very
powerful psychic
isabel
but that wouldn't be enough to cross
over my mon would need um
divine assistance
to cross over
no one would need the help of
god
the help of god no way
yikes i know you've never had much faith
you've never had much reason to
that doesn't mean that we don't have in
you
maybe put on your sirens
she's learning
[Music]
at least he loved bugs
[Music]
and well
got faith
by the time we were 10 they started
forcing her to take antipsychotics of
treatments and they would come for her
and she'd look at me and she'd say to me
why why don't you tell them angie that
you can see him too i said
i don't see anything
she protected herself until one day i
finally stopped seeing i abandoned her
john i left her all alone what an
interesting shot
you do this there's no turning back
you see them they see you
understand
yeah
rachel weiss we're gonna need you to cry
like
every like two to three scenes
so do i have to take the rest of my
clothes off for kind of
john
i'm thinking
john
on the spot
[Music]
i hope they banged at least once in real
life i mean look at them you have to be
fully submerged for how long
as long as it did
take a deep one
yeah
is constantine's watch waterproof
damn they really kept her underwater huh
i thought the shower was just going to
go on for like two minutes
you gotta die
oh god this is not comfortable
[Music]
this is
uncomfortable
yikes
submerge yourself
freezes
oh my god
oh cool so in that like split second she
went to hell
that's cool what a great handling of
perspective
you gotta turn in your badge
you've been cheating this whole time it
was his
rolling not of all
something smaller
shiny
she spent six months learning how to do
that what about the balance half breed
to the scales when you started killing
my friends
i'm just adding some counterweight
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
cool
[Music]
i want one
sex in the city poster
lust ultimate sin
fornication
think of it as a bulletproof vest
i want counter reefs to protect me
[Music]
oh nice
i was bored of this
how's my mind crossing over you have a
piece
[Music]
oh god you left something important
behind didn't you
son of a [ __ ] don't find it johnny boy
enjoy
damn that practical effects it looks
great
[Music]
i love it
[Music]
oh
icky
good god
ah guys some good effects in the name of
the father and the son and the holy
spirit
the blood
of god
he found it
whatever killed the son
of god
will give birth
to the son
of the devil oh god
literally
i was making [ __ ] up you have to ask for
a solution to be forgiven
[ __ ]
she
was my only mission
and you brought her right
to us
so does this walking fast mean you found
something jesus didn't die from being
nailed to a cross he was killed by a
soldier's spear yeah
i'm a catholic john i know the
christopher that's what the sphere of
destiny is
i
threw out the sister as you've asked
some qualities remind me of pirates of
the caribbean where's the ambulance
it's about to be taken
what's wrong
i don't know i just feel take the
[ __ ] whoa
damn
that was nuts holy [ __ ]
oh my god
nipple chills
wow
[Music]
you're breaking the rules
screw the balance
you're the only one still playing by the
rules midnight and while you've been
imitating switzerland people are dying
hennessy beeman are you your friends
wants to remember
i need your help
[Laughter]
forgot how big it was
200 souls passed through this wooden
steel at sing-sing
wow
[Music]
which way is east
great follow-up after watching the green
mile
this isn't about the girl
definitely mostly not
about the girl
show about this
i don't know what the [ __ ] going on
[Music]
oh man well
[Music]
[Laughter]
his visuals are gnarly certain objects
most notably either of the two crosses
of stereo have been used by even the
unordained to bless and sanctify
commonly occurring waters
even
what are you doing
right
okay
come on
[Laughter]
okay even the pool shaped like a cross
what is it
i'll speak
kind of worried child labof's gonna die
my name's john
you are in violation of the balance
[Music]
immediately
or i will deport you
all of you
go to hell
awesome
cool
[Music]
charles
[Laughter]
oh my goodness
looks like a [ __ ] alien
[Applause]
oh poor woman
[Music]
is
[Music]
that can't have been that simple huh
no no no no no
no no no no no no no no
what is it
oh god she is really selling the [ __ ]
pain oh my god
[Music]
[Music]
not bad you hear that
the way that is is because
this is kramer
chaz kramer
[Music]
yikes
damn they got some like good jump scares
in this [ __ ] man
[Music]
no
it isn't
no jazz
so those tats are more than just hats
[Music]
oh my god call me provincial i'm simply
seeking to inspire mankind to all that
was intended
by handing earth over to the son of the
devil help me here
[Music]
you handed this
precious gift right
each one of you
granted redemption from the creator
murderers rapists and molesters
all of you you just have to repent and
god takes you into his bosom
in all the worlds in all the universe no
other creature can make such a boast
save man it's not fair
over
the labels on her response not brisbane
tags gabriel
you're insane
the road to salvation begins tonight
she's so [ __ ] good man
[Music]
know i'm one of your favorites
he's becoming a believer
in your house
why did you spell
attention please
damn crazy he's looking at the camera
it's kind of like putting it in god's
perspective we are god
[Music]
hurry
it's kind of cool how the shards of
glass on the doors gonna make it look
like angel winks
i unleash you unto this world
what does satan think about all this
disgusting shot
[Music]
blue
what took you so long
lucifer
hello
i did hear peter stormer was in this
movie i learned that forever ago
you're the one
so i would come up here to collect
myself
let me help you
see
sunny
i've got a whole
theme park full of red delight very
different than the lucifer from the show
sauce
families tuned just fine
busy bees are busy busy
need a vacation
where's gabriel hmm no accounting for a
taste really
they have the sphere of destiny
they had the spear of destiny
yo
i really like what storm mayor is doing
or is it another one of your cons
he's like
[ __ ] some villain out of a ridley
scott movie
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this world is my
time
you best of all of us gabriel should
understand
i am
fisher
i will smite thee
in his
honor
come on gabriel
looks like somebody doesn't have you
back
come
anymore
[Music]
love is so demonically expressed so cool
so cool
i do not think this film will be as wild
as it is
you're willing to give up your life so
she can go to heaven
fine
it's done
oh man he's so good
i love him john
i'm so used to people playing the
[ __ ] devil and
i really feel like he's doing something
different
[Music]
what
[Music]
[Music]
no [ __ ]
the sacrifice
that's right
[Music]
oh my
goodness
show me christ
belongs to me
[Music]
[Laughter]
you
[Applause]
the chance to improve
in hell
you
will
live
not pleasant
very not pleasant indeed
[Music]
at least he knows he's got a shot at
having
[Music]
now he can fight the good fight
oh her wings have been clipped
human
you don't deserve to be human
[Music]
be the hand of god
it's your choice
it's always been your choice
now yeah
that's called pain
get used to it
[Laughter]
i have something for you
john
why are you giving me this
rules
hide it
somewhere no one will ever be able to
find him denny's
i've got some cleaning up to do
[Music]
[Music]
no
too bad those soap opera qualities don't
pay off in the end i guess there's a
plan for all of us
i had to die
twice
and narrate works his work in mysterious
some people like him
some people don't
always cho and gum
i
i want a sequel give me a sequel that
was cool let me see if there's a
post-credits scene there is a
post-credits scene apparently yeah i
thought the world building was awesome
it was the world that inhabited
you know it's like a
gothic religious action horror film come
on
how awesome is that reminds me of things
like the crow or not necessarily the
matrix but something closer to
dark city doom and gloom ominous vibe
grungy i love it it's awesome that's
some qualms with it but for the most
part it's pretty cool it's pretty cool
stuff reserved for some of that thought
process for when's the post-credits in
place you guys know so i was wearing my
keanu reeve shirt the whole time damn
it's released in 2005.
oh we're never getting that sequel
really feel like this might have gotten
received better now than
back then i don't know something tells
me like if you try making this now might
be a little bit more
fast pacing goof not that it was slow
but you could see a rushed version of
this now something out of like the soda
universe or something like that but
that's why i really uh i i was i was
enjoying it it felt like an actual film
you know and not something that was
trying to
be
be part of a bigger cinematic universe
what 46 on rotten tomatoes ah screw that
that's way better than that blaze's new
few new trails and bogs down a confusing
narrative muddle what's confusing about
it i don't know it's kind of like a
faith-based movie in a certain way
enjoyed it
cheers
you did good
oh
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ] chaz is an angel
he would have that reaction oh that's
nice
totally sets up that sequel that
he would work with chaz to
take down more of the evil i would love
to see what shia labeouf today would do
that sounds like it'd be distracting
[Music]
alrighty let's talk about it all right
so unfortunately at the time of shooting
this i don't really have much time to
talk and normally i like to talk for
quite a while
after i i watch a whole movie as part of
the fun of deep being able to deep dive
in but i have to keep this uh a lot
shorter than i normally keep it so i
just got to be like really direct and
straightforward but i like this movie i
liked it a lot it's too bad didn't get a
sequel doesn't seem like they're gonna
be able to get a sequel but man you know
i've
been recommending my way
and the fact that like uh i've seen sort
of a resurgence of this film popping up
in the last couple of years so maybe
never say never and the fact that keanu
reeves is still going strong and is as
popular of a commodity as ever
i could see them doing a sequel and this
is like my cup of tea you know at our
patreon page uh we know not to just make
a shameless plug for the patreon screw
it we cover um supernatural over there
and we're like 10 i think we're on
season 10 yeah season 10 of it and so
you know there's a lot of things in here
where i'm like yeah this is my jam you
know dealing with the
smart ass main character who does a lot
of exorcisms and fights demons with cool
kinds of demonology
gadgetry uh i love it i think that's
like really cool stuff and especially to
watch
this film
in a time when you know like back then
there weren't that many comic book
movies you know comic book movies were
starting to have
a rise to say the least
but
now there's a sort of kind of formula
you sort of expect not not that to say
every one of them is formulaic
however there is a
similarities and patterns and a certain
kind of consistency you see with films
in the comic book movie genre
so there's something actually kind of
refreshing about watching this one now
and i do think that if they did try to
make this now it probably would have
been like maybe it wouldn't have
embraced the sort of slow burn but it
feels unique
and
it
it feels um
like it sounds sounds really strange to
say but it just feels like an actual
film
versus trying to you know it has like a
post-credits scene at the end which
feels like it's definitely setting up a
sequel and even the way it ends with
you know lucifer coming to visit john
constantine it does feel like yeah we
are in the
middle of possibly getting a potential
sequel
however it still
still works without there being a sequel
because there is a complete story told
of john constantine this man who you
know survived a suicide
and uh
can be you know
selfish and cold and then he does a
selfless act
by the end of it and then even decides
to start working on not because like the
the cigarettes and the fact that he's
developed cancer he's slowly just been
killing himself over time like there's
such an emphasis on the fact that he is
smoking has developed cancer due to it
and now he's working on actually
bettering himself and healing and
perhaps still doing the kind of actions
john constantine does
but
in the name of fighting for god or
something i don't really know what it is
uh what what he would be fighting for in
the future but there is an actual arc to
the character and so that's why i feel
like as a
and it's not as super in your face they
don't clearly state it
even though it is very clear they don't
have a bunch of lines that are showing
in and i like the way the arc unfolded
because i wasn't even thinking about it
sometimes i i jump a little bit ahead
and i start to think like oh he's
probably going to do some type of
selfless act i thought it might have
just been him working with rachel vice
that would
be the selfless act but to do the
ultimate sacrifice and how that actually
gets him into heaven like he's able to i
love that of how
it it solved two problems um
one by you know uh like by by uh cutting
out his own wrists he was able to summon
lucifer who wanted to take him to hell
so that was able to stop
uh
satan's son from doing what him uh i
already forgot his name my god it's not
mammoth is it mammoth i forget but it
was able to stop his son
and then on top of that it was able to
redeem his soul to be able to go
to heaven and i love the illustrations
that this drew upon you know like i i
don't know what the constantine graphic
novels or the comics necessarily look
like but it felt like a comic you know
it felt like paintings being brought to
life
and
that was some of the i think easily
something that i feel like many people
probably really appreciate about this
film is the hellish landscapes that they
brought whether it be through
the the unique innovations of the
villains uh like the having that bug
creature early on was awesome or then
appearing through the mirrors you know
there's a version of this from like sam
raimi could have made like a really
probably more much more campy version
but i like that it embraces this slow
burn
detective
like
neo-noir thriller angle
and you just don't get a genre of film
like this i'm not sure how well it would
do nowadays but in terms of just
accepting this film on its own merits
the the genre and the mood and the tone
it committed to from beginning to end
like it never felt like it was
starting to get in a rush or they were
trying to wrap too many things up you
know like constantine was a cool
character
and i liked the supporting cast
surrounding constantine as well the the
priest who was helping him out earlier
on in the film the one with the alc the
one who
had the the need to drink
that actor who you know has been in so
many things a monster identities he's
one of them like the main personality
from identity and a bunch of other
things he's a wonderful actor i love his
personality the
the papa midnight jamon hansu the role
he serves and
uh freaking uh tilda swinton is gabriel
uh that
sort of
like i couldn't even quite tell if it
was like
androgynous is the word right of
because i can't tell if gabriel's woman
or man doesn't really matter seems to be
kind of in the middle of both and uh i
love the portrayal she brought peter
stormer for the limited amount of screen
time peter storm mayor has i'm so used
to him just playing russian bad guy
and he brought something so different
and i
want to see more constantine to also get
more peter store mare because he was
excellent he had these really
fascinating idiosyncrasies and and weird
ticks uh this eccentric personality and
also felt part creature like you know
because when you go to hell
you have
this sort of
i said the upside down so it took me a
little bit of time to realize it was it
was hell but that's what i thought was
cool was that it felt like a a messed up
parallel version to earth
you know that it's like the the way the
sins around us uh are are very much
prevalent that it is hell on earth and
then the alternate it feels like an
alternate dimension and so looking at
the visuals with a lot of these
monsters that feel
they're not
zombies in the sense of how they walk
super slow or some [ __ ] uh but there is
something zombie quality like where it
feels
animal instinct
in the way these creatures behave
so i think the world building they did
was really neat because a lot of the
time
with movies especially nowadays when
they do world building it feels
like they're jamming too much in there
or that it's all
being built because they want to get a
franchise going but it seemed to all
keep serving the immediate plot
at hand and the plot was interesting
enough
as it is and uh i so yeah i think the
the music was cool i think the visuals
were very neat i love the composition of
a lot of the shots it really because
like the the one of the films i grew up
on um
religiously i would say
there were two movies i watched all the
time when i was a kid
um the crow with brandon lee
and scream those were the two movies i
watched all the time easily undoubtedly
so yeah and and so when i see something
like this that has that gothic flair to
it that feels comic book inspired but
it's really just his own movie
i i'm all on board for that because
while this is all very supernatural
leaning
it also has
that that that like twisted
apocalyptic sci-fi touch that you would
get in those late 90s movies and early
2000s films so i love the hodgepodge of
it um joe also jamon hansu's papa
midnight was a really great character
like the way they set these characters
up i found myself wanting to see more of
them
rachel vice is
is really good in this movie uh
undoubtedly like with what they gave her
to do i didn't really feel part of my
qualms with the film comes in
just weirdly as much as it was like big
impending doom stakes um you know i i
never
really
you know as much as a an invincible
assassin john wick is i tend to worry
more for john wick than i do for
constantine and this is dealing with all
kinds of craziness but i never found
myself
concerned or on edge
or
[Music]
buying in or like constantine really
being a friend that's part of his
character i get it that he's he's so
cold and like too good at his job
and uh so there's a bit of an apathetic
quality to him
and
i so i understand that
at the same time though
that was part of the thing is while
there's a film that had a lot of really
cool horror a lot of surprisingly good
jump scares
there
was certain sequences that i found very
thrilling yet overall
it didn't quite reach
an intense level that i felt this film
was trying to sort of achieve
like weirdly
it was kind of intermittent for me that
the
it didn't have this consistent suspense
to it or this consistent like intense
pulse yet i was always entertained yet i
was always uh you know amused by what's
happening yet i was always appreciative
of a lot of what they were doing
visually on screen and what the
performers were also doing
so
i think that's a big thing for me though
is i i kind of got a fear for the main
character just a little bit and i never
did
so that was one thing that was kind of
holding it back for me a tiny bit and uh
the chemistry between him and rachel
weiss i get it they were kind of going
for like a film noir type of uh
room
because it's definitely like a sexual
tension and romantic chemistry they were
trying to at least paint even though
it's so much more than that it's so much
deeper than that um there's a there's a
natural there's a genuine tenderness and
care
i didn't really find their chemistry
that strong and and they're i guess it
might have something to do with the
intentional like it felt very purposeful
the their delivery with each other
like he had a combination that was also
a little bit of john wayne to it
and she was always so
there's a bit of coldness to the
dialogue and again part of it actually
feels intentional
so
i admire it in terms of
a an observation piece of it and i'm not
just saying it to be nice
i did admire it yet it left me feeling
kind of detached from being emotionally
clicked and tuned in
with the journeys of what they're going
through
you know
and to me that's always so important as
part of my movie going experience is as
i've got to be really tuned in for that
yet i do think that the world they built
and the adventure they lay place and
i love the world of the plot set up of
this whole thing you know of god being
this i like those and i like story i
think the first thing really introduced
me to something of a god who just
abandoned his people
uh was uh
what was that mini series that was based
on a play angels in america angels in
america was the first one and
supernatural really does that too and
other properties as well but the you
know god is not really a
presence who gives a [ __ ] about humanity
and so it's like everything is like book
of job in a lot of ways yet he doesn't
really care for
no no there's a bit of a book of joke
quality to it i would say but yeah you
have god and the devil who uh it's all
big it's a big wager uh between yeah
it's definitely a book of job in a lot
of ways but
a lot colder i would say so yeah the
world between that they struck between
god and the devil and then what
humanity's role is in this in the middle
of a wager i think is a really
fascinating concept to deal with
and i like keanu reeves performance yet
i do i do think that is
that's probably the main hindrance for
me is
i i felt
not as connected even though there were
certain scenes that i thought were like
i was cl i was clicked with it
there i
wasn't as um i just wasn't as attached
to the emotional experiences but i was
always fascinated by everything and
normally if the character thing is not
hitting me that hard
then i'm kind of just bored so i was
kind of fascinated with my own
experience of but i'm still really
enjoying like the concept in the world
and and everything that that's unfolding
and the actions and the visuals and like
every all the art design the productions
everything about it was so cool to look
at and i was more
i felt more emotion towards those things
than i did about the journeys these
characters were going on so
to me it was i it was one of those
things that i that i was watching going
by bet
with a sequel
they could have improved upon all those
things and kept everything that made
this one all the great things about this
one and then just improved upon it with
its sequel
it even charlotte buff was good really
reminded me of his character from my
robot
okay have you guys seen i robot comes at
the beginning in the end
he's a kid who wants to know when he
buddies with the main badass character
there are some similarities between that
character those characters so yeah for
the most part i thought it was a really
uh entertaining film and
uh again the
like very heavy on the exposition as
you'd probably expect with a film like
this but it still felt very unique and
you just don't see films like this and
i would absolutely like if they
announced the sequel i'd be super duper
stoked about it i would love it because
you know i don't want it to
i don't want it to misconvey i actually
did really like keanu reeves a lot in
this film like i thought he was really
[ __ ] cool
and uh you know i know it's not the john
every portrayal i've seen of john
constantine there are similarities
this is very key on reeves like this is
super duper keanu reeves whereas the
other portrayals i've seen in
constantine are
you know
uh yeah i believe he's british right
like
there's a very specific type of like
loose not quite a drunk but you feel
sort of a drunk kind of character like
there's qualities that are very similar
between all the kinds of constantines
but this felt very much like keanu
reeves was doing just keanu reeves thing
while playing john constantine so i
but i like it i thought it worked for
the movie that they were making here i
thought it really worked and i thought
keanu reeves did a really good job and
he was really entertaining
so yeah and
you know what it was for rachel weiss
that was kind of missing for me and i
get that her character was going through
the most vulnerable experience of her
entire life is there were there were not
enough moments that i felt that
i want i found myself craving i wanted
to see what made her such a high level
detective other than the fact that she
has these abilities that make her such
an amazing shot and can detect people
and stuff um like detect who the bad
ones are i was missing that like i
wanted to see the the strong detective
character as well shine through and i
never really quite got that granted her
character in the most vulnerable spot
and they did something different that
was
that could have made this character
actually very cliche and they still did
different things with her so there's a
lot to be appreciative of so even on the
parts that i have criticisms i find that
there's also a flip to my criticisms of
but i do something i appreciate about
this as well again not just saying that
to be nice um that's the thing that
helped keep me engaged and entertained
throughout so i'm glad i watched it
finally that was awesome and [ __ ]
gianna reeves just i think constantine
with the beard would even look
even cooler so let's get it going let's
get it going come on constantine too
make it happen guys what do you think
about this film would you want a sequel
even though it's been [ __ ] almost 20
years would you want a sequel leave your
thoughts down below subscribe click that
bell leave a like thank you for the
support catch you guys soon
[Music]